to Hollywood stars accused of modern-day
McCarthyism upon news of a fundraiser
for President Trump in Beverly Hills
will and great stars are calling to
reveal Hollywood's Trump supporters
Aaron McCormick tweeted hey Hollywood
Reporter kindly report on everyone
attending this event so the rest of us
can be clear about who we don't want to
work with thanks his co-star Debra
Messing followed suit tweeting please
print a list of all attendees please the
public has a right to know joining us to
react his host of the Michael Knowles
show Michael Knowles Michael
unsurprising behavior from Hollywood
here am i right what's strange about
McCormack's tweet is last I checked his
show got canceled a month ago so I'm not
sure that he has the chance to work with
really anybody at the moment but people
keep comparing what he tweeted and what
Debra Messing tweeted to McCarthyism
what they did is far worse than
McCarthyism Joe McCarthy for all of his
faults at least was going after
communists what these two actors are
trying to do is go after people who
support the American president people
who want to make America great again
that is far far worse and it shows you
just how perverse Hollywood is in 1999
when Elia Kazan won his honorary Oscar
you had major stars in McKellen Edie
Harris were sitting down there refused
to applaud for him I wonder if those
same stars will stand up against this
type of McCarthyism the one silver
lining here is it's a lat at least
Hollywood showing their cards you know I
know just about every conservative in
Hollywood because there simply aren't
that many of us it's a pretty small
community and I know a lot of people who
have been blacklisted by the industry
who have lost a lot of money who have
lost a lot of work simply because
they're conservative or they're
Republicans or they're patriotic and
they were a make America great again hat
and at least what this is doing is
showing just how vindictive and in just
what an anti-american tenor Hollywood
really has doesn't that scare you a
little bit though that they're showing
their cars because this stuff used to
happen in private right they used to try
to blacklist people who were in
disagreement privately now they're
totally unapologetic they feel like
there's gonna be no consequence they
feel like there's this collectivist
bubble they live in so they're just
putting it out front and center that
makes me a little bit worried about
what's happened to Hollywood even in the
last couple of decades
I got to tell you I sort of like the
honesty you know Hollywood is very good
at hiding its intentions they're like
very good actors out here and I'm glad
that they're at least showing what they
really believe you know president Trump
is excellent at this he's excellent
making his opponents expose their true
feelings in 2016 he made Hillary Clinton
come right out and say that she thinks
half the country is deplorable and the
irredeemable and it seems that Hollywood
is expressing that same thought right
now let Americans judge if they want to
go to the box office they can if they
want to turn on TV they can otherwise
they can tune it out